hi there my name is bradley and
i can easily prove that to you by
showing you my driver's license
which i have there i could actually use
any other form of id i could
get out some of my credit cards and show
you my name or even maybe have a look at
my passport
but how would i prove my identity online
i mean which methods currently exist for
online identity verification anyway and
what are the dangers
that are associated with that well today
we're going to be talking about just
digital identity
[Music]
now with old school paper or plastic
documents everything's pretty
straightforward
i mean when i'm issued something like my
government passport or my id
the government effectively takes on the
role as the guarantor
guaranteeing the validity of these
documents
mr bean are you presently on any kind of
medication
the problem is however that these
traditional kinds of documents
can be difficult to use in digital
contexts
and until recently there were really no
systems in place that could tell
whether a digitally uploaded document
was real or
fake nor were there really any means of
protecting the information
on these documents from being stolen
digital identity verification goes back
as far as the mid-1950s
back then nobody would have even dreamed
of owning a personal computer
because back then computers were the
size of your living room they cost
millions of dollars and they also
required dozens of people to operate
[Music]
however back then data protection was
less of a problem as operators used
these things that were called punch
cards
now the punch card itself contained the
computer program that was needed at that
time
and at the end of the day these punch
card operators would
take out the punch card put it in their
backpack and go home you see these boys
this is it this is the program for
revolution
but this punch card system didn't
satisfy one particular mit student by
the name
of fernando kobato now he was frustrated
because he had to actually wait hours to
use his university's computer system
just because it could only handle one
user at a time over the course of five
years kabato managed to develop a system
that allowed
multiple people to use one computer at
the same time and to classify the data
that each particular was
able to work with colbato came up with
usernames
and passwords which we're very familiar
with today
but what was once fairly revolutionary
80 years ago
is causing serious problems in today's
world you see logins and passwords can
be guessed
through what's called brute force now
this is when an
attacker submits passwords over and over
again until they get the right
combination
to try and combat this login attempts
are often limited and captures are
commonly used as well
another key problem with passwords is
that they're entirely anonymous
there's no way to prove that a password
actually belongs to you personally
i mean think about it like this imagine
your driving license didn't contain your
name
photo age or any other identifiable
information
i mean would this document have any
meaning at all i mean anyone else in the
world could use this very document right
well that's the problem with passwords
once they're stolen proving your
ownership can be
difficult if not impossible one hacker
exploited this very problem
his name is kevin mitnick but unlike
many other hackers
kevin didn't break into computer systems
he simply extracted login information
directly from his victims when i was
younger i was really fascinated with
telephones
computers and magic and i became a
hacker now the password system hasn't
aged very well in this age of internet
services
this should mean that most of us have
dozens if not hundreds of
individually unique passwords to
remember what does it as it turns out
over 60
of us use the same passwords over and
over again
for different services so it goes
without saying
that this is incredibly dangerous i mean
once someone has access to
one of your accounts they'll have access
to all the rest so
let's try and do a quick experiment i'm
going to check a service that checks if
your email
is listed on any stolen databases
see my email was leaked over two years
ago from a website called
canva and to be honest i don't even
remember why i registered on that site
but
luckily the password i used on canva
wasn't used elsewhere
so nobody was able to hack the rest of
my accounts
pretty good now an alternative way to
protect yourself is to use a program
that saves all of your passwords
for example password enables businesses
to store multiple encrypted passwords in
so-called vaults
now this is especially important for
companies with lots of passwords
floating around and
these passwords can be stored on the
cloud or they can be server based
many browsers have similar systems built
in if you're looking for something
on a smaller scale but if you're a
business passwork works perfectly
[Music]
now this term digital identity has
evolved tremendously
in this age of social networking i mean
since the early 2010s facebook twitter
and google have let users log into
multiple
online services through their existing
accounts
in other words your facebook login can
function as a universal key
for whichever services you use so
in effect your facebook account is
functioning as an id
since it's tied to you personally now
there are many benefits to this system
most obviously you don't need to
remember multiple passwords which is a
huge plus
especially if you're registering for new
services you can get
registered in a click and it's also
easier for service providers to identify
you as the true account holder
if anything goes wrong but the downside
is that you are in fact
giving up your personal information and
this information can
by the way be monetized by social
networks in all sorts of ways
including but not limited to targeted
advertising you'd be shocked to find out
how much of your personal information is
actually being collected
go ahead and log into google and take a
look at all the personal data that has
been collected on you
here you'll effectively see everything
you've ever done on google
from youtube videos you've liked and
watched to
airline tickets that you've purchased
seven years ago
because of this it's really no surprise
that with all of this information
google was able to conquer over half of
the over 300 billion
online advertising market in 2020.
in essence social networks are actually
taking on the roles that are
traditionally played by governments
as profiles function as online passports
obviously
this has exacerbated the issue of false
identities
as until recently it was not too
difficult to create a false identity
by simply changing your age your gender
your name
or even your biography or you might have
stolen the password to someone else's
profile
or simply bought one of the many
profiles that are readily available for
sale online
[Music]
fortunately it's a bit more difficult to
pull this off nowadays because
most large internet services have
introduced something known as two-factor
authentication two-factor authentication
operates on the principle that users
have
any two out of the three following
identifying factors
number one they need something which
only they know such as their password
for instance
number two they need something that
belongs to them for instance their
personal email address or their phone
number
and lastly they can use something that's
unique to them which could be their
biometric information
for example fingertips so now to access
your account
it's not enough to just know your
password you'd also need access to your
phone number for instance where a
verification code could be sent via sms
for high-risk internet activities such
as banking biometric verification is
often used
now this means that two-factor
authentication might include something
like
fingerprint scanners or face id but
in any case authorization is occurring
both in the digital
and physical worlds and this reduces the
risk of hacking tremendously
but with more safety comes less freedom
this could be a problem our phones leave
a vast number
of so-called digital footprints a phone
might leave behind their
imei their serial number a browser key
or so on
and therefore our phones are just as
unique as our fingertips
right or our face so technically people
can be identified simply
by the devices that they hold and this
is something that law enforcement has
been catching onto in recent years
and please by the way do leave a comment
if you'd like to hear more about digital
footprints in more detail
and i'll respond but now let's get back
to digital identity
you can verify one's identity by using
another method
which is basically uploading their
physical documents in digital form
however it's not enough to just upload a
photo of your passport or driving
license in fact to get verified properly
or to verify someone else's document
properly you need to go through
three steps now number one you need to
determine the information on the
document
if you're using an online engine you
might do this via ocr
text extraction right now second of all
you need to determine the originality of
the document itself
this is detecting things like forgery or
graphic editing software right
now number three you need to determine
whether or not the document actually
belongs to the individual
who has uploaded it now in this case the
computer system that verifies the id
acts like the teller
at a bank it checks your id and
signature before allowing you to make
any transactions
computer says similar systems are
already in place in the car rental and
credit industries
for instance and actually in another
video i checked whether these systems
could actually determine a fake document
if you haven't seen it i left a link in
the description also it might be on
screen
somewhere now so click it but after this
video governments all over the world can
no longer ignore the need to create
verifiable digital documents in fact
india is one of the pioneers of this
over 1.3 billion indians are listed in
the nation's ui dai database
which contains biometric data on each
and every citizen
including things like fingerprints and
retina scans
this system is already in use for
keeping tabs on the hours worked by
government employees as well as
elections and items in the banking
sector now this is the largest biometric
system
in the world and thailand pakistan and
indonesia
are not far behind currently working on
very similar systems
however one drawback of this system is
the amount of
power it gives to the government and
many might think that this is
getting dangerously close to a sort of
orwellian nightmare
[Music]
nonetheless india's biometric system has
actually caught the attention on the
world stage
and in may of 2016 the un launched a
project
named id 2020 now this was launched with
the intention of creating digital
identities for
every single person on this planet by
2030.
now this system is in fact aimed at
helping stateless people in particular
as it gives them the opportunity to
effectively prove their identity in any
part of the world
all of these digital identities would be
kept safe and sound
on you guessed it the blockchain making
them
impossible to be destroyed or even faked
for that matter
lilu dallas multipass digital dense
systems are also being developed
elsewhere
in countries such as the uk for instance
canada australia belgium and luxembourg
but estonia in particular is working on
a blockchain based system
for storing personal data which is
fascinating
moreover very unsurprisingly germany is
in the late stages of developing a
system that allows citizens to keep
their ids
right on their cell phones how
convenient would that be
now among more recent developments there
will also soon be many systems worldwide
that track
whether or not people have been
vaccinated against covert 19.
so is it about time that we start
compiling all of our digital identifiers
all of our accounts our biometric
information and so on
into a singular digital identity
well that is a tough question i mean on
the one hand this would certainly
eliminate the need to remember multiple
passwords right
nor would you ever need to prove that
you're not a robot by
identifying some images that match of
traffic lights
i mean but on the other hand i wouldn't
want to give up any remaining semblance
of a non-digital personal life
would you make sure you subscribe to
some sub and join
our excursion through the damp
forests of the online jungle i'm bradley
i've been your host and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you